mais changeant changé ma vie l'onisep et
triponez fripounets auquel j'étais
abonné c'était le magazine de jeunesse
où on pouvait découvrir les différents
métiers liés à la cou à la ddt rédaction
d'un journal un personnage de cette
rédaction m'a particulièrement marqué la
maquettiste ailes coupées découper
coller et décoller monter démonter
bref un joyeux bordel en devenir c'était
ce que je voulais faire
à cette époque j'étais au collège la
deuxième chose qui a changé ma vie c'est
l'onisep
comme beaucoup de monde ou pas oui oui
l'onisep vous souvenez quand on est au
collège et qu'on va consulter cette
fameuse brochure avec des flèches tous
azimuts des rectangles des ronds des
critères et surtout des pré-requis bref
une formule magique tout lisse est toute
propre
pour arriver à ma destination en fait
c'est ce que je fais aujourd'hui
consultant de communication print et web
à l'époque
voilà ce que l'oni c'est de me proposer
j'ai donc pris mon paquetage une
boussole et ce schéma pour entamer un
parcours tout lisse et tout propre sauf
que dans la réalité
mon parcours ressemble plutôt à ça
en fait j'ai un sens de l'orientation
aussi performant que ce monsieur vous le
reconnaissez c'est marcus un acolyte
d'un certain et indiana jones
marcus aurait parler plusieurs langues
et médée parmi la population locale
sauf que dans la réalité
ce bibliothécaire s'était déjà perdu
dans sa propre bibliothèque au rayon
toulis et tout ranger mais revenons à
nos moutons comme marcus je me suis
rapidement sorti du schéma préétabli
voir près magie dans le même temps on
nous explique que si on a le malheur de
ne pas suivre le schéma préétabli
les conséquences peuvent être terribles
mais pourtant j'ai déconstruit les mises
en page de l'onisep pour reconstruire
ceci comment vous êtes sceptique c'est
vrai comment atteindre une destination
avec un trajet pareil alors c'est la
demande une petite explication et un
retour en arrière direction 1998 après
un bac littéraire arts plastiques
on vous fait atterrir en deug d'arts
plastiques jusqu'ici tout semble aller
bien puisque l'onisep lui dit les
conseillères d'orientation qu'on
rencontre en troisième et en terminale
le disent aussi en plus c'est rassurant
c'est un peu comme ces personnes peu
confiante sur la route avec leur gps
vous savez quand votre gps vous dis que
dans 500 mètres vous devrez tourner à
droite
une appréhension s'installe au moment du
changement de direction
le coeur s'emballe certains d'entre vous
ou même se mettre à transpirer quand le
gps dit maintenant tournez à droite une
fois le changement de direction au péril
celle ouf de soulagement
et bien la voix du gps c'est celle de
l'onisep et de la conformité
si beaucoup s'y fier j'ai fait ma marque
us
j'ai écouté la voix du doute qui s'est
installé pendant la fac pour aller ma
destination dans la voix de maître de
mon enfance me rappeler que je voulais
sur la voie de la fameuse maquettiste de
fripounets ainsi la sortie du sentier
battu direction bts s'impose d'autant
qu'une autre surprise de la vie va
chambouler le schéma semble ont risqué
et flippant et l'arrivée est la surprise
de cette de la vie de la vie c'est
l'arrivée de mon fils et l'arrivée de
mon fils a été tout sauf une promenade
de santé
en avoue avoir des contretemps aider à
lire dans son destination il ne faut pas
lâcher
cela étant les aléas que je vous ai
cités vont dépasser l'entendement géant
prévient certains d'entre vous notamment
les migraineux
je vous conseille une bonne aspirine et
une tisane premières joies du schéma non
lissé nom propre
c'est à la paix a mis la protection
maternelle et infantile
quand la puéricultrice découvre que je
suis des cours par correspondance et
qu'en plus il faut travailler en
entreprise pour des stages obligatoires
elle me propose de repousser voire
d'annuler le bts pour jouer les bonnes
mères cela aurait selon elle cela ne
rentre pas dans les caisses de temps
d'autant que franchement le choix du
cnete permet d'anticiper d'organiser une
nouvelle vie de mère et une vie
professionnelle
non mes études à distance permettent de
se libérer des contraintes horaires d'un
établissement landa le cna nous
aurait-il dû puis à l'insu de son plein
gré et cette dame du crous rencontrés
lors de ma demande de bourses d'études
ce serait tellement yvan trompée elle
qui m'a soutenu que mon projet était
viable puisqu'elle venait d'aider
récemment une étudiante dans le même cas
que moi
pourtant la voix d'une jeune abonnés de
free faune et que j'étais dit continue
ne lâchez rien t'es mise en page tu
feras malgré les à lire cela dit les
conditions d'une étudiante classique est
idéal ne sont pas là mon bureau de
travail et la table basse de mon séjour
les horaires composer avec celle d'un
enfant de base âge certains des devoirs
noté effectué de 21h à minuit voire une
heure du matin
certains l'ont compris
je suis une maman sous l'eau encore un
aléa qui avec mon mari ainsi
après la sortie du bts je n'ai pas
écouté la voix de l'onisep qui me disait
faut continuer par une licence
professionnelle en effet à la maison on
mange des pâtes des pâtes et même pas
des panzani est plus le temps pour
continuer les études faut que je mange
ainsi démarre une nouvelle étape de mon
chignon lisse et nom propre pour arriver
à simple certains le constateront il ya
une banane ceci est un aléa et ne
provient pas de ce fruit si bon sur la
santé est riche en vitamines b
pas du tout un jour visite d'une
assistante sociale qui a remarqué que le
fiston cavale et beaucoup en fait il est
tonique et en plus il parle souvent de
manière incompréhensible
bref il ne rentre pas dans les clous du
moins pas dans les mises en page d'un
manuel du type mon enfant de la jalle de
la naissance à l'âge de trois ans comme
ce type de manuel qu'on s'achète avant
quand on devient maire en à la crèche on
ne s'était pas inquiété puisque ça leur
conseil était de consulter d'abord un
test auditif pour voir si tout va bien
puis une consulte en orthophonie le cas
échéant pour finir m6 car le bonhomme
n'est pas concentré dans ses activités
ni plus ni moins
seulement un feu dans un habituel chez
un enfant est devenu enfin non
habituelle chez l enfant est devenu un
fait anormal est très déstabilisant pour
des personnes comme moi qui avance dans
star propre vie avec une mise en page
bordélique mais quand il rentre dans sa
finalité
on ne panique pas plus que ça mais pour
ceux qui avancent dans leur vie avec un
schéma semblant cohérent mais bordélique
dans sa finalité c'est les 18 jeunes
mise en balle d'une mise en cage
infernale on peut même dire une mise en
cage implacable puissance yves plusieurs
rendez-vous en centre médico
psychologique pour au final est envoyée
l'enfant en établissement spécialisé
on dit que c'est pour quitter le
bonhomme puisse poser sa concentration
et à mieux parler une sorte de schéma
toulis et tout propre pour que l'enfant
puisse être hub sien lorsqu'il rentrera
à l'école temps estimé de cette mise en
page semblant minitieux un an ou deux
sauf que le bonhomme il restera quatre
ans jusqu'à ce que je mette fin à une
mise en page faussement cohérente et
froissé dans sa finalité
et pour cause sans avoir eu le temps de
comprendre ce qui se passe le fils est
catalogué dans la case autistes et
déficients intellectuels et moi par la
même occasion mère indigne et
irresponsable car mehr solo habitante
d'une banlieue sensible est les
pronostics sont que le bonhomme sura
soit délinquants soient maltraités soi
un paumé où les 3
j'espère que vous allez bien
est ce que ceci était juste le début
d'un bazar son nom la maquettiste de
griffonner a mal à la tête
on ne les entend moins savoir pour le
coup en fait la maquette east et vous
allez à un peu halluciné je poursuis
deux ans plus tard hommage à méchant mal
de crâne matin ou aussi un anévrisme
cérébral dont j'ignorais l'existence
joue les trouble-fête dans mon
itinéraire
ils seront et m'envoie l'hôpital en fait
il devient la troisième chose qui a
définitivement changé ma vie cette vie
qui aurait pu s'arrêter net pour moi et
l'avenir de mon fils qui aurait pu
s'arrêter net pour lui il aurait pu ça
ils auraient pu être enfermé dans la
dans la cage d'une mise en page douteuse
sans personne pour le sauver après la
sortie de l'hôpital sauvé par un
homologue du docteur shepherd mais à la
coupe de cheveux complètement différente
je décide de reprendre la mise en page
que j'avais établi auparavant dans la
finalité est d'aller de vivre et de
devenir
n'en déplaise à l'unicef qui se tord de
rire
omv à me voir me dépatouiller dans une
mise en page 12 avance lentement mais
sûrement
n'en déplaise à cette dame d'une
structure dont je tairai le nom qu'ils
disaient mais madame si vous voulez
évoluer dans votre vie proulx vous ne
pouvez que postuler pour des contrats
spécifiques aux habitants d'une zone
sensible urbaine
même si le contrat consiste à balayer la
station mir du moment que je rentre bien
dans ma cage le pardon case
au final je fini par devenir consultant
de communication où je mets en page des
cartes de visite des brochures des sites
web
en fait je met surtout en page ma vie et
ce principe c'est comme la sncf
le plaisir ne vaut que s'il est partagé
par tous alors mon fils aussi ira livra
et deviendra n'en déplaise à
l'établissement spécialisé
il sortira pour aller à l'école n'en
déplaise à l'école il y sera content il
s'est fait des copains
il y travaille malgré l'étiquette qu'on
lui a collée content côte east est
attardé mental
n'en déplaise à l'étiquette qu'on lui a
collée sur le front
je l'emmène à l'hôpital qui me confirme
que non le fiston n'était ni autiste ni
déficients intellectuels comme on a
essayé de me le marteler via un
signalement auprès d' injustice car le
loupiots fans de lego avait juste un
problème de concentration un souci
d'attention qui aurait pu être traité
comme un navire pas comme une mise en
page aboutissant à une mise en cases
alors franchement n'hésitons pas ne nous
laissons pas enfermer dans les cas ce
qu'on nous impose encore moins à celle
que nous nous imposons faisons à une car
en fait elle nous tiendrons hors de la
vie hors de notre vie faisons notre mise
en page même lazare 2 et même caste même
aussi casse tête aux yeux de la
conformité de la norme de l'onisep et
cetera de tout ce que vous voudrez
faisant enfin notre put faisons notre
propre mise en page qui nous mènera à la
vie et à l'identité qui est la nôtre
merci